خبر اللي راح اقوله يمكن يكون غريب من
نوعه بس في نفس الوقت يمكن يعجب كثير
صراحه من اللي بيعانوا خصوصا من عدم
القبول خلال مقابلات العمل بسبب مثلا
المظهر او بيعانوا من التوتر من انه تكون
الشركه طالبه مواصفات معينه في الشكل مو
متوفره فيهم او كذا يعني ففي شركه صينيه
حلت الموضوع وطلبت من المتقدمين لوظائف
فيها انهم يجوا لابسين اقنعه مثل مو
شايفين قدامكم والسبب انه هذه الشركه تريد
ان تحقق العداله وما تختار على اساس
المظهر ابدا يعني نقدر نسمي الموضوع قناع
العداله الوظيفيه ومو بس المرشح بيلبس
القناع لا كمان اللي بيعمل معه مقابله
العمل بس ما اعرف السبب يعني بصراحه ليش
بس انه قالت الشركه انها كمان بتقدر قدرات
الفرد اكثر من المظهر وانه لبس القناع
بيقلل من اجهاد المقابلات للمرشحين يعني
الشركه تبغى تمسح عباره حسن او حسنه
المظهر اللي بنشوفه شروط طلبات التوظيف
وحقيقه انقسمت ردود الافعال على اليسار
فمنهم اعتبر هذه الخطوه المناسبه للناس
اللي عندها توتر وقال لك من مقابلات العمل
وفي ناس لا يعني عمل دعائي للشركه والناس
بتحاول انها يعني كده تثير وسائل الاعلام
كذا بتجذب اهتمامهم والكلام هذا كله وعلى
فكره مو بس لبس القناع اللي كان لافت خلال
المقابله لا في شيء ثاني الشركه كانت حاطه
موظف جلس بيوزع قصب السكر على المرشحين
ليش يعني ما اعرف ما اعرف لسه الموسم
طلعها يعني